hey guys I'm Walter benezia and this is
top five after looking at his worst last
week today
we count down the top five best
performances of everybody's favorite
movie football coach Denzel Washington
as stated last week Denzel has been
around for decades and it's earned the
respect of many of his peers and fans
over his long and fruitful career with
seven acting Academy Award nominations
and two wins so far with one pending
Washington has solidified his place in
Hollywood history several times over at
this point his filmography is filled
with performances that connected with
people and received massive critical
acclaim it was exceptionally difficult
to choose his top five best performance
and so believe me any one of the
honorable mentions that I'll show you
could have easily been on this list as
well here we go these are the top five
best performances of Denzel Washington
number five Malcolm X in Malcolm X
definitely one of his most well known
roles Denzel as Malcolm X earned his
third Oscar nomination and was the
second of several team ups with director
Spike Lee this biopic follows the
titular important and controversial
public figure it spans most of Malcolm
X's life while showing him at his lowest
point in prison in the 1950s converting
to Islam becoming a leader and public
speaker in the Nation of Islam while
also covering his leaving of that
religious group and assassination some
of his impact on african-american
culture is examined as well this movie
is three and a half hours long and the
story behind making it this way is an
interesting one within itself because of
that runtime we got to see plenty of
Denzel playing Malcolm X at a very young
age the detail in those early scenes at
another layer on top of what we knew he
was to become why don't you want to look
like what you want what makes you
ashamed of being black
[Music]
when he changes into the persona history
remembers him as Denzel nails just about
every detail we get a few clips of the
real Malcolm X at the end of the film
and you can see how far Washington went
to properly portraying him this is most
evident in the speeches he makes
throughout the movie oh I see it I see
it again
Ben Han as Malcolm X evolved and left
the Nation of Islam another aspect to
his character has brought forth in the
film he felt betrayed by the group that
made him what he was and began to become
very paranoid and nervous that they were
out to get him
those suspicions were well-founded and
Washington did a great job showcasing
those emotions this movie was surrounded
by controversy from the get-go so it
says a lot that Denzel was able to cut
through that noise and deliver a
performance that was pretty much
universally loudest number four Rubin
the hurricane Carter in the hurricane I
had always wanted to see this movie and
upon watching it wasn't what I expected
in a good way
the hurricane tells the true story of
middleweight boxer Rubin Carter and his
false imprisonment for a triple murder
he did not commit it's partially adapted
from Carter's autobiography the
sixteenth round from number one
contender two four five four seventy two
and covers the attempt by Brooklyn
teenager Leslie Martin and his Canadian
foster family to release Rubin from
prison while the film was critically
acclaimed it has been criticized for
some heavy inaccuracies - what actually
happened concerning Carter and the
events surrounding it
this was another complicated real-life
person that Washington played really
well like in Malcolm X we get to see
Rubin Carter at a few different points
in his life
we see him as a boy a young man fresh
back from time in the military
his main run as a middleweight boxing
contender and his long stay in prison as
Carter changes as a person Washington
put forth physical and mental changes to
the character that instantly indicate
alterations to his mindset for example
there's barely any boxing in this movie
but
when there is you see the great shape
Washington got into for this role and
the ferocious demeanor he displays
towards his opponent
[Music]
as the film goes on you see Carter
stripped away of his dignity in prison
his time in solitary confinement is a
testament to Denzel performance as we
see the character both breakdown and
rebuild his mind to protect themselves
away
Thank You mr. Connor
feel welcome mr. Williams when Reuben
meets a young fan of his autobiography
that proclaimed his innocence named
lesra you see hope returned to him and
the character develops even further you
give them hope yes you do you give them
hope because you have transcended less
very important to transcend the places
that hold us you know that when lesra
brings in his foster family to help
prove Reubens innocence we see a roller
coaster ride of the motion that has
Carter give up several times before
fully allowing them to aid in his
struggle for justice I've been locked up
and so he is I put a lot of good
people's lives at risk
then those performance is so good here
that it elevates those around him
whoever he interacts with in this movie
is brought up to his level he has a very
powerful screen presence here that he
continues to display today like I said
not exactly what I expected but it
turned out to be a really heartfelt
story based on a real man's experience
and Denzel brought him to life on screen
number three
William whip Whitaker in flight the buzz
behind this performance a few years ago
was huge and after seeing the movie I
can see why whip Whitaker is a
commercial airline pilot who
surprisingly functions at a very high
level despite being an alcoholic when a
mechanical malfunction causes his plane
to nosedive he somehow were gains enough
control to crash-land miraculously only
six of the 102 people on board died in
the disaster however due to the alcohol
and drugs in his system at the time of
the crash the investigation threatens to
expose his addiction and possibly even
caused him to serve jail time
whip tries to quit cold-turkey but finds
out just how strong a hole his
alcoholism has on him as he spirals more
and more
of control Denzel tackles addiction in
this film and the results are nothing
short of amazing it's a raw performance
than a unique from his previous work
with is a very very flawed man not a bad
man his alcoholism is in full control of
his life for most of this movie it's a
heartbreaking realistic portrayal of a
person who has 100% surrendered two
advices and we see him try to get his
life in order several times we watch
them struggle with temptation and those
moments are so intense
Denzel doesn't even have to say a word
and we are on the edge of our seat
[Music]
what's even more pathetic for his
character is when we see the remnants of
what his life used to be there's a point
when he goes to the house of his ex-wife
and son it's a different type of take on
a scene like that then they'll played it
dangerously he's in full denial and once
again we can't look away from the
self-destruction I'm telling you to
leave sorry the manor house now you
upset my mother you've got to go you're
well I'm your father tough guy she was
drunk oh I'm a drunk you don't know well
tell me we see Denzel character his
absolute rock bottom in this film and
stay there for a while it's a
performance that should be seen he just
comes off so wheel here I choose to
drink you do yes I do
I don't see all that choice I think you
drinking I'm and I blame myself I'm
happy too and you know why because I
choose to drink I got an ex-wife and a
son I never talked to you you know why
because I chose to drink also the plane
crash scene at the top of the film is
totally thrilling and terrifying
director Robert Zemeckis put together a
fine film here glued together by Denzel
Turner's Whitaker powerful stuff what
could be better let's see number two
Troy Maxon in fences I'm surprised by
this two benches is still in theatres
and still pending our denzel's Oscar
nominations for both Best Actor and Best
Picture he also directed this film based
on the play by August Wilson fences
tells the tale of Pittsburgh sanitation
worker Troy Matteson Troy was a great
baseball player earlier in life but was
too old by the time major league
baseball started admitting black players
this expired dream has always eaten away
at him and affects his family life with
his wife and son Maxine is a complicated
man who has a strong sense of duty but
has a darker side to his personality
that comes out when triggered I think a
lot of people will be able to relate to
this film it's a gripping family drama
that is led by one of themselves
greatest performances I'll admit when
the film starts off it's very dialogue
heavy and feels like a play I'm sure
that has a lot to do with the fact that
August Wilson wrote the script for this
film before his death in 2005 however as
the movie goes on I either got used to
it the dialogue lessened or both but by
the end of it I was blown away by the
performances not just from Denzel
but Viola Davis and even Michael T
Williamson as well I was right here with
Detroit I got a life too
I gave eighteen years of my life to
stand in the same spot as you don't you
think I ever wanted other things don't
you think I had dreams at Hope what
about highlights what about me in the
hands of a Tyler Perry I can see this
film easily being a pandering mess but
under the careful direction of
Washington it feels like an
all-encompassing human drama that the
performances carry a lot of the cast
including Washington portrayed these
roles in a 2010 Broadway revival of the
play that may explain why they seem so
comfortable with their characters then
those performance is flashes but we all
know he's probably the best at that
there are intense and quiet moments
mixed in with a very authentic feeling
father-son relationship that becomes an
emotional turning point of the film as
long as you in my house you put a seal
on the end of it when you talk to me and
so if you eat everyday there's still got
a roof over your head there so got
clothes on your back yes sir why you
think that is because of you hell I know
it's because of me but why do you think
that is cause you like my recommendation
check out fences as soon as you can this
was a difficult one
then Zola has a ton of amazing
performances that I could have gone with
so before we get to number one here are
some well-deserved honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Denzel
Washington performance is detective
Alonzo Harris in training day as soon as
I started rewatching this movie and saw
Denzel first scene it was instant this
is number one veteran narcotics
detective Alonzo Harris welcomes rookie
J coy to his Los Angeles unit by quickly
showing him the rough side of the job
Voight soon questions whether or not
Harris's lion walking methods truly
serve the greater good or just his own
best interest what's so fascinating
about this performance is denzel's
unpredictability you never really know
where he truly stands that element to
his character makes for some fantastic
scene unfortunately doesn't work that
way good guys they die first right the
school kids and mom family men they
don't want to catch the stray bullets in
the noodle to protect the Sheep you got
to catch the wolf and it takes a wolf to
catch a wolf down at that he has great
chemistry with co-star Ethan Hawke the
two playing off each other made for the
perfect dynamic one a la cama witness
this is the best one Institute
which it kind of just you know take your
time you may play the game you're old
wise and then you can change me but you
gotta change him from the inside
yeah he's frickin great here's some more
clips you've been planning this Otis
I've been planning it all week son the
shit's chess it ain't checkers King Kong
ain't got hockey if you've never seen
training day I could not recommend it
more for that performance Denzel and
quite possibly his most iconic role I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your favorite Denzel Washington movie
and/or performance what do you want me
to cover next in the show leave a
comment and let me know go back and take
a look at last week's video where we
found Denzel top 5 worst performances
and make sure you check out awesome
comics from yesterday where Ayanna
Porter and Heather asked does watch them
suck follow me on Twitter and awesome
underscore Walter to take part in more
polls about what may be covered in the
future come back next week for another
lovely episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you